[Music]
you seem to be getting a lot of heat for
putting out funny vines that people
enjoy yeah
well thank you I do a lot of ones in the
car that people always will comment
under it like hey you're going to get in
Iraq because you do them as you're dry
yeah and people catch me too
like because you know it cars up windows
and so yes they still yeah even still
dude and I do like singing ones a lot
and people will drive by sometimes my
windows are open and I'll be like
killing it singing like I don't like
it's funny because singing is funny but
I kill it like you're shooting yourself
yeah I do like this and I'm driving like
this and yeah it's so [ __ ] so unsafe
don't do it don't do it you have to be a
professional yeah I mean yeah he's
clearly know what you're doing yeah and
I'll sing and I'll kill it and then
people will catch me and I'll just look
at them while I'm singing you got to own
it you know I'll just look at them and
be like yeah I do you make eye contact
you make them sort of complicit hostage
in Europe yeah sick family we're gonna
do drive off the road you can I'll catch
up and just now if they get behind me Oh
be anywhere near you when you're driving